you guys make chips as big as your head
of course you do because it's America I
always take people talking about Cool
Ranch and I don't even know what Cool
Ranch is I could you like Cowboys like
but really cool cowboy cool mmm tastes
better than normal life Nacho Cheese
Doritos that's what cool Cowboys would
probably taste like they should bring
that here flamin hot whoa they're like
bright red oh that stinks don't have any
like fluorescent red food oh we're good
with beer really hot they're flaming hot
even no good I don't know how someone
could eat like a whole bag of that just
one of that is very spicy
our old mate cheeto here is experiencing
what I've been going through right now
just like with my hair like bright red
slam jams slam jams beef pork
mechanically separated chicken as
opposed to hand separated this is actual
meat or okay I don't know what's in it
it feels like a sausage that's been like
put behind a sofa for a while that
tastes really good actually I'm a Jenna
they're not that bad it has the
consistency of like dried foreskin it
tastes good but after reading the
ingredients you know I don't really want
to eat any more of them won by world
famous easy cheese I don't even know
what to expect here made with real
cheese I find that hard to believe I'm
no cheese expert but I'm pretty sure it
doesn't come in a can there's there's a
button so you just like put your finger
over ahh
oh [ __ ] it's like popping a zit oh it's
actually not as bad as it looks like
it's going to be tastes kind of like our
cream cheese America is trying to make
things that will outlast humans somehow
you guys seem more happier and I'm right
now I'm booking a one-way airfare to the
United States
Wow